-Welcome back.
I'm here with Dakota Johnson.
Dakota, you're not afraid
to tell it like it is,
so I thought that
we'd have some fun by asking you
to settle some of
the biggest debates of all time.
Are you ready for this?
-Yes.
-It is time for
"Dakota Settles It."
-♪ Dakota settles it,
Dakota settles it ♪
-Alright.
-Wow. I love that.
-First issue...
Better rom-com -- "The Notebook"
or "When Harry Met Sally"?
-"When Harry Met Sally."
-I agree.
There you go. Next.
"Game of Thrones"
or "Lord of the Rings"?
-Oh, that's tough
because I feel like
people will be really angry
on either side,
but...I'm gonna say
"Lord of the Thrones."
-[ Laughs ] Oh, my gosh.
Oh, my gosh.
Next. Could Jack have fit
on the door with Rose?
-Yes!
Even if he was on top of her.
-[ Laughs ]
How would he get on top of her?
-What do you mean?
-I mean, you're -- you're
swimming for you life there.
It's freezing-cold water.
-Yeah, you just, like,
hoist up and slap on.
[ Laughter ]
-Here we go. Alright.
Is it "GIF" or "JIF"?
-It's GIF.
-It is JIF, but it's GIF.
You're right.
-It's GIF.
-But the guy who invented it
said it's JIF.
-Who's the guy who invented it?
-Uh, Fred...Jiffy...
uh, Mendelson.
[ Laughs ]
Alright, here we go.
"Sex and the City" question --
Should Carrie
have ended up with Big?
-No.
-Yeah, I agree.
It ended bittersweet and cool.
SJP's awesome. Perfect. I agree.
Great. Alright.
Take a look at this.
Is the dress blue and black
or white and gold?
-It's white and gold.
-Correct.
-But it actually sort of looks
blue and gold.
-It does a little bit.
It's like a light blue and gold.
-Yeah.
-I agree. It's neither one.
Trick question.
Alright, next up --
Team Jacob or Team Edward?
-Oh, um, Team Edward.
-Yeah, I think so too.
Next, how do you pronounce the
word at the bottom of my screen?
-"Cara-mell."
-Yeah.
You're classy,
'cause I would've said...
-We're not disagreeing on much.
-..."car-mell."
But --
-Do you say that?
-I think I say "car-mell."
"Car-mell"?
-"Cara-mell?"
-"Car-mell."
It's -- What I'm saying is
wrong. "Car-mell" corn.
"Cara-melled" --
"Car-melled" apples?
"Car-melled" app--
-"Cara-mell" apple.
-It sounds much better
when you say it.
"Car-mell" apple doesn't sound
like that. Yeah. Alright.
This next one, remember,
there are four to choose from --
best "Toy Story"?
I know the answer.
-Oh. Um, I like "Toy Story 3."
-That is correct.
That is the right answer.
-Is it?
-Yeah. It's definitely 3.
3 should've won
for Best Picture.
It's one of the best movies I've
ever seen in my entire lifetime.
-Yeah. I agree.
-Does cilantro taste like soap?
-No.
-Yeah. I agree.
-Oh.
-And finally,
one of the most debated
questions ever,
were Ross and Rachel on a break?
-Yes.
-They were!
I totally agree with you!
You heard it here first.
My thanks to Dakota Johnson.
Her new movie "Our Friend"
is in theaters
and on demand this Friday.